the Joe Rogan experience look at that
Wow in addition of mammals cats kill in
addition an estimated 300 77 million
Birds and six hundred forty nine million
reptiles every year in Australia that's
[ __ ] nuts
far out yeah you know some [ __ ]
brought him over there not that long ago
I think they brought them over in the
1800s yeah I've heard like a couple of
different cases where that they bring
people in and notices yeah something
just went backwards for them yeah you
can't just bring things places you can't
just did you know what's actually
predators well the cane toads
so they got introduced for I can't men I
know you mana fear this one but they
bring him in and now they're just a
complete lock Pierce like they're they
those big [ __ ] yeah they're big they
bring me for probably for some other
stupid reason I remember yeah beetles in
the sugar fields 1935 these [ __ ]
they're brought to Australia from Hawaii
with the intention of controlling the
cane bead on the sugar cane fields in
North Queensland cane beetles live on
the high upper stalks the cane plant
cane toads can't jump up that far so
they barely had any impact these [ __ ]
idiots they didn't know jack-shit 1935
they couldn't Wikipedia [ __ ] right some
some idiots like you gotta justify your
job toads we're gonna bring toads look
at the size of that prick look at the
one in the middle click on the middle
person look at that look at those [ __ ]
yeah man
Jesus Christ well they started off
though all up though up north in like
Queensland and then they just now
they're now they're all in New South
Wales and they just expand it's just
they're gonna take over so I don't even
actually this is this is that's arrived
knew about luck eight years ago so it's
probably quadrupled by now or like they
probably have covered it all around even
know what are they used to kill the cane
toads they're gonna bring in birds have
we talked about the for pest campaign
that's like anxious not ancient but like
it's a historical event that happened
that looks like the death of three
five million people in China know yeah
they had a sparrow problem or swallows
whichever would small bird mm-hmm so
there was there an annoyance that they
allowed people to kill them
they're like bang pots and pans to get
rid of them that work to get rid of them
but then all of the bugs then ate all
the rice fields that led to a famine
that led to 25 to 35 million people
dying oh geez yes they would have been
better off with the birds
yeah well it's like a whole it's a
historical event that people need to
keep in mind when these things happen
that there's a very sensitive ecosystem
yeah was that a 1935 nobody learned yeah
get rid of those frogs do they have an
idea I don't know I mean I don't know
too much I just remember hearing that's
that's all fallen froley out there but I
don't know it's buddy I think I mean I
remember seeing videos of and there was
like just the floors absolutely covered
of in certain spots up in Queensland
like absolutely covered like actually it
was in a Simpsons one that was it was a
simpsons episode yeah I woulda causes
for something like that someone comes
they beat him they like they plop stick
the for pest thing was a couple years
later is 1958 to 1962 interesting so you
learn from 35 well maybe those toads
taste good maybe they should start
eating toads
I think frog legs are delicious are they
poisonous no maybe not maybe not cane
toads poisonous
I'm fine down here that's have you ever
had frog legs yes I have well they're
cooked well they're good I did have that
and I was actually what was it it was
actually a mixture of I thought chicken
and fish the ones I had yeah boiled toad
eggs oh boy toad eggs so they're vent
they have some sort of poison says yeah
there came two those poison glands
through their whole life cycle mmm
animals they it's bad for animals
oh well that's great that means you
can't eat them that means these [ __ ]
they're running around making sure that
predators don't eat them no bigs
I'm animal to bring over here to kill
beetles you [ __ ] [ __ ] he should
find that guy from 1935 and kick his ass
go back in time like what we thinking
man what a dumb move like over a poison
toad that no one can eat what I said
well as the foot bug said literally for
bugs that's crazy yeah and the fact that
it's poisonous which is not venomous
poisonous which means if they eat it
they die so these predators if you
brought over a bunch of [ __ ] jackals
or something to go eat the frogs yeah
are the toads they would wind up dying
cane toads oh they do have venom
secreting poison glands known as
paranoid glands or swellings on each
shoulder where poisons released if they
are threatened when they're threatened
if ingested the venom can cause rapid
heartbeat excessive salivation
convulsions and paralysis and can result
in death from any native animals great
with predators God it's well maybe we
get the cats to eat the cane toads maybe
that's the move I swear look I could be
wrong the mercy look at this the most
humane way to kill cane toads to put
them in the freezer alive humane that's
the most humane I think I remember
getting told like that back in the day
like you you had to kill him if you seen
him or something like oh that was a that
was a kill if you can the month's
popular method was used to kill millions
of poisonous pets until it was banned 20
years ago because Animal Ethics
committee's considered it inhumane oh
you [ __ ] it's all those [ __ ] animal
rights people they ruin everything
what about our rights huh you got poison
toads everywhere [ __ ] how do you get
rid of it what does it say remove toad
temptations and make your home a cane
toad free zone you know sign you decide
hey we're at cane toad free zone yeah
cover or bring pet food in at night as
it attracts cane toads remove standing
water oh great
how you can do that what about ponds
what about puddles remove rubbish and
other degrees debris so cane toads can
shelter under it during the day keep
your outside lights off when not needed
keep toads out by creating a barrier far
far out indeed I don't know that offense
if they can't jump that high just hire
people aren't be able to kill him give
them a lot make it valuable to kill them
I'm telling you I think it was Furby I
think that honestly I remember if you
save on a lot of thing you you had
taught under supposed to kill yeah I
don't know it could be wrong maybe I
just heard that from someone and you end
up with a good archery practice if you
had a lot of arrows you know because
it's not a big target it's a good thing
to shoot at [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] bring
over [ __ ] poisonous toads estimated
over 200 million so you have so crazy
that's so many toads 200 million toads
Jesus Australia yeah I don't know about
that one crazy
[Applause]